the resistance in pancheer appears to be
holding out for now but look at this
the taliban rolling through the entrance
to the valley heavily armed with
american equipment captured when the
country fell in the rugged mountainous
terrain above anti-taliban fighters
standing their grounds
the taliban failed to take this highly
symbolic territory when they last ruled
as did the soviets when they occupied
the country in the 1980s
celebratory gunfire did puncture the
night sky in kabul when taliban sources
claimed the area had fallen
but the movement's jubilation appears to
have been premature
former vice president amro lasalla quick
to deny they'd been defeated in this
clip posted on social media
the reports i've fled are propaganda he
says
there's no doubt the situation is
difficult but the resistance continues
the humanitarian situation is also
desperate
some aid arriving but it's not enough
and until the airport's fully
operational things are likely to get
much worse
in kabul taliban checkpoints command the
city where the price of food and basic
supplies is increasing all the time
people here after 40 years of war are
tired and don't know what to expect next
afghanistan is a place on the edge the
west's presence here now a ghostly
shadow and nothing sums that up better
than the abandoned jail at bagram where
the detritus of america's forever war
lies abandoned
the project to turn afghanistan into a
democracy needed huge amounts of force
and coercion
here the empty handcuffs on the wall a
reminder of how it failed
alex rossi sky news